[Music]
first
impressions mata that much we know and
for an anime character to have a legacy
in a show
their introduction is probably one of
the most important things a good debut
can help a character hit the road
running while a flat one can doom a
character to mediocrity unless something
magical happens in the long run
today we'll be having a deep dive and
looking at the top 10 most badass
character introductions in anime
we could say that these characters have
had some of the best debuts and i think
that the way they debut did wonders for
their popularity moving forward but
before we get going i'd like to
encourage you to like and subscribe to
the channel it helps my channel grow and
it will only take you less than a second
let's try to hit that one million subs
milestone together
for those of you who love japanese
history the name hideyoshi should ring
lots of bells
one of the most legendary figures in the
sengoku era just a tear below nobunaga
deserves nothing less than a grand debut
thankfully sengoku basara gives him just
that
this is one of the surprisingly badass
introductions in anime
standing atop a hill with practically no
one else but himself
he bravely stares down armies out for
blood then
the arrows come and he reflects them
with nothing but his outstretched fists
yep that just happens and it's a surreal
sight to see what an introduction
hideyoshi is the only person who doesn't
use a single weapon
all he needs are his fists and strength
and in the war-torn era of armies and
military
you don't get any more badass than that
we've known gojo for a lot of badass
things come on just look at the top
jujutsu kaizen moments video i posted
and you can immediately see how many of
those involved this badass mentor being
awesome
and filling us with awe however while it
was his fight with jogo that made the
internet explode he didn't have the
shabbiest of introductions either right
off the bat we see him being his
whimsical self you'd expect anyone to go
all
out in that fight against an
aggressively attacking yuji but gojo
just toys with him throughout you know a
character is badass when he can just
playfully toy with an opponent out to
kill him
surely a preview of things to come when
he finally decides to be serious against
the other curses
future trunks takes the next lot on the
list
[Music]
the character from the future coming
back to change the past storylines being
done a lot in anime already however
among such instances
few characters could come back and make
an impact as big as future trunks did
future trunks arrives to warn the good
guys about the looming bad future
featuring the androids and he comes face
to face with frieza and king cold
remember frieza remember how much
trouble he gave the good guys this must
mean there's an epic battle ahead
well not really if you need any further
proof of shonen power creep
this moment is a good example as future
trunks handily dispatches both
frieza and king cold this does get the z
fighters attention and we can finally
move on to the meat of the ark a great
way to build future trunks up as a
fighter but it's also amusing how
quickly frieza got turned into fodder in
this story
[Applause]
[Music]
next up we have levi's introduction in
the first season of attack on titan
with how many highlights levi has it can
be easy to forget where it all began
so here let me give you a refresher
course on the epic introduction that he
had way back
like a blade that rends despair levi
comes in from the sides and showcases
some top tier titan slaying action
the first of many that he'd commit to in
the series i think that what makes this
moment so cool is the music it just
works so well having it blare while he
slowly analyzes and breaks down the
invading titans with his team
hanji joins in on the party too but we
all know who the main star of the moment
is now don't we spinning through the air
and finishing the last titan with an air
of cool ruthlessness
levi shows us how you introduce
humanity's strongest soldier
sword of the stranger wastes little time
in introducing its primary antagonist
the invincible wall
and the all-powerful storm that our
protagonists must overcome in the
movie's early moments we see luong take
on an entire squad of bandits in one of
the best character establishing moments
in action movies it's not a battle
but a slaughter as luo lang the ming's
master swordsman
makes easy work of the bandits the
numbers game never really mattered and
it's all quality over quantity in this
massacre just seeing this moment live
made me curious in anticipation of
what's to come with this master
swordsman
how would our heroes overcome him or
would they even be able to
those are some questions that a badass
character introduction makes you ask
and i'd say that luo lang's introduction
in the movie did an awesome job at
building hype for the character
[Music]
we follow that with another villain
appearance this time by utsuro just when
you thought that the trouble had ended
a mast villa makes his unwelcome
appearance for the characters what
seemed at first to be masked mook ended
up dazzling all three of them with
excellent swordsmanship and unparalleled
power a three on one should be fine for
our heroes right
wrong mask guy proceeds to easily defeat
nobume
sogo and kagura only being fended off
with the arrival of gentoki and only to
reveal shoyo's face
more questions pile on as gintoki breaks
down setting the stage for the next arcs
and adding even more intrigue to what's
already been a very gripping story you
know utsuru means business from this
appearance alone he'd then go on to
establish himself as one of the most
broken villains ever in anime
fourth place is kizaru from one
talk about a grand entrance it's not
just anyone who can come in and drive
zambodi crazy with one impactful entry
coming from the sky the admiral makes
his presence felt almost
immediately with a visual like that of
him standing triumphantly in front of
the smoke and flames
you know this guy means business it's
just something to see him look so
unfazed and no
cell or the feeble attempts at his life
where he so nonchalantly acts towards
the destruction that he's capable of
sort of reminds me of gojo too
and like gojo he's a lot more relaxed
than his outlook seems to imply
some people argue that kizuru is one of
the most important and noteworthy
admirals
and while most of it came from his role
in the story i do think that without his
impactful and badass debut
he wouldn't have hit the ground running
as fast as he did in terms of popularity
and buzz
[Music]
eskanor one of the greatest and most
powerful members of the seven deadly
sins
certainly owes his reputation to his
impactful first appearance
[Music]
if i were to show a non-finer picture of
the seven deadly sins and make them
guess the most overpowered one among the
bunch i think that not a lot would pick
the big
goofy looking guy with a mustache
however escond proves that appearance
isn't everything and the far more
important than appearance is a strong
first impression even the initial
impression for esknow seemed like a flop
at first with him being knocked out
quite easily at the hands of galland
however
morning comes and eskino shows off his
true form in one of the most badass
turnarounds you'll see in anime he then
proceeds to do eskenal things and
straight up destroy galand in one hit
talk about a strong first impression
that quite literally came out of nowhere
right
sunshine
[Music]
for me how bad a character's
introduction is shouldn't just be
determined based on the physical
destruction
or the special effects that come along
with it it should be memorable
and it should be impactful so despite
not having inflect superpowers will come
heralded by lightning and earthquakes or
anything of the like elle's introduction
makes
such a large impact due to his showcase
of deduction skills
he first appeared in the series after
baiting light to kill a wanted criminal
in live television his daring and quick
resolve showed that he'd indeed
pinpointed light's location
and had an idea of how the murders were
being carried out he quickly proves that
he's highly intelligent
and that he'd catch up to like yagami to
face off against the genius like like
yagami
someone truly remarkable had to enter
the stage and what better hope to face
off the inscrutable intellectual power
and morals of light than the
non-descript self-absorbed law
[Music]
finally we close with who else but
madara
mother has been so tied with naruto's
law ever since the story started taking
a more serious turn a legendary figure
known to be responsible for so many of
the things that shaped the world until
now
and his power was a thing of legend now
at the climactic arc of the story
that power was about to be unleashed
such was the hype surrounding madara a
character who deserved to be the
ultimate test
the ultimate villain in a story like
naruto considering the hype surrounding
him and how relevant he is in the grand
scheme of things a glorious introduction
is the least of the requirements
and kishimoto simply hit a home run with
his introduction i know one man army
entrances are a dime a dozen in the
world of anime but seeing madara live up
to the hype was just a thing of beauty
for me and the good thing about this is
that the momentum from such an amazing
debut carried over into his subsequent
battles with him just being unstoppable
heck mandala himself became too powerful
for his own good so he had to be written
out
so what do you think any of those first
appearances made a big first impression
on you i'm sure that some of you can't
wait to share your thoughts on any
character that i may have missed so
let's head over to the comment section
have a casual chat
if you enjoyed the content of the video
let me know by hitting the like button
and sharing the video with your friends
introduce vinitube to a friend today and
we can continue growing as a community
if you feel like helping the channel
grow with monetary contributions however
you can opt to drop by the channel's
patreon or being a channel member feel
free to choose your pledge option and
each pledge matches in helping me bring
in bigger and better content in the
weeks to come
that about wraps it up thank you for
watching and i hope to see you again
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you